con esta consigna niños y jóvenes de
nueva york salieron a las calles en el
mes que busca generar conciencia sobre
las armas de fuego y para pedir que se
tomen acciones ante el incremento de la
violencia en eeuu
todo el mundo aquí es una víctima todo
el mundo aquí es un testimonio de lo que
significa estar afectado por la
violencia de las armas
en chicago la ciudad vivió su fin de
semana más violento en 5 años que dejó
más de 50 personas tiroteadas en
diferentes hechos y nueve muertos
mientras tanto y con pocas expectativas
de ser aprobado por el senado en la
cámara de representantes inició el
debate de un proyecto de ley destinado a
endurecer las leyes nacionales y saint
jacques usted dice que es demasiado
pronto para tomar medidas que estamos
politizando estas tragedias para
promulgar nuevas políticas ry irs han
pasado 23 años desde columbine 15 años
desde virginia tech 10 años desde sandy
hook rangers extendido demasiado pronto
amigos míos qué demonios están esperando
y waiting for
y es que este miércoles en oklahoma hubo
un nuevo ataque un paciente le disparó a
su médico tras quejarse de sentir dolor
luego de una intervención quirúrgica el
atacante compró el arma de camino al
lugar de los hechos ante las continuas
noticias sobre violencia armada la
vicepresidenta kamala harris llamó al
congreso a tomar medidas weening
necesitamos que el congreso actúe al
sheriff pero sé que todos pensamos lo
mismo sobre la importancia de que los
líderes el líder en en temas como éste
en otro caso que alertó al país el
supremacista blanco que asesinó a 10
personas en un supermercado en búfalo
nueva york se declaró no culpable de los
25 cargos de los que es acusado el
debate nacional sobre el uso de las
armas y la segunda enmienda continúa
sobre la mesa y la respuesta al problema
estaría en manos del senado
estadounidense